how's it going guys welcome to an update
on ancient archer game engine here on
code tech tutorials my name is matt and
i'm just going to show you the changes
since the last vlog i believe the last
vlog i
i don't even know what i talked about i
think i was talking about how everybody
should make a game engine
and that was a lot of fun and i've been
working on this and improving it i think
i'm going to try to do these
monthly so as you can see here i've got
some more
model loading capabilities
fbx files can have the textures embedded
within them
so i added in some functionality if it
finds an embedded texture
it will attempt to use it and will read
the data
and i will show you the code to do that
because reading it from a file is
there's a lot of examples of that you
can find it on those tutorials but
reading from this embedded texture
was a little different and this guy
right here is from
the miximo site and i've got him all
loaded up
from embedded textures i've just put
some basic controls here to move them
around
can also move that ship back there which
is another fbx
you'll see a little tearing on that i
think it's i'm not sure why that
happened something to do with the render
distance
but it doesn't seem to happen on this
other model so might have not tried
playing around with ways to get rid of
that but doesn't seem to want to go away
on that model
might just be a limitation of something
some way they made that model because it
was just a free one
but this guy doesn't seem to do that if
i move him
way back he doesn't start getting all
jaggy textures
okay let's bring him back forward front
and center
and i want to show you where i got him
from it's just from this site there he
is
as you can see this has reflective and
shadows and all that kind of stuff you
don't see that in ours
we're just loading just the diffuse
texture that's one of the current
limitations and something i plan to
address pretty soon
so one of the big future plans is
getting some pbr shaders in here
loading and all the different textures
combining them up and making it look
really cool and eventually shadows too
okay so how do you load i have
i had some kind of object dump oh yeah
i'm also playing around with
running and debug which usually i only
do release
so debug is showing me some new things
that
uh i'm trying to figure out like i'm
getting some memory leaks that i
never knew about so i have to analyze
into that they don't seem to be hurting
anything
but memory leaks are never good so i've
got to look carefully at where that's
happening
maybe it's with this new code i just
introduced i'm not sure
okay so previously when we loaded you've
seen
with this scene loader this is
essentially a model loader more than a
scene loader
normally we would just process each node
uh
so this is a lot of code i will get to
the
uh the good part here so when i'm
loading my material textures
that's where all this happens and we do
this check here
you gotta take the ai scene and
see if you can get an embedded texture
and if you do then you gotta load it
from
memory rather than from a path so
that's basically what i do here oh this
is all just commented out okay
so basically i just do that i do a
texture from
data which is a new function i added
into the texture loader
so texture loader now has texture from
data you can pass it an ai texture
this is one from one that's embedded and
you could still use
stb or stbi which is what we were using
to open and load
well just load files from file data but
these uh these ones you can do it too
you just got to use
sdbi load from memory rather than what
we're using before
uh just plain old load with a file path
so we do that
load from memory and we get the the data
and we figure out all the size stuff so
you're welcome to look at this code it's
all in here
and committed to the branch of ancient
archer on my github
it's on master and development i think
right now i just synchronize them for
now
so i can continue on so yeah loading
those it was a little tricky to find out
there wasn't a whole lot of
documentation on this i just had to
piece it all together
try it out until it worked so yeah the
next big step is to load more than just
the diffuse
and then get that in a shader and then
models will look even better which isn't
too far off i'm getting close to that
another big thing i did was the sound uh
some of you might
already be aware of that but i was
really playing around with sound a lot
getting sound effects and music
and our listener all ready for the
engine that way we can have
a positional sound when we develop our
little games
so i guess i'll just show you the
asteroids game because this has
improved a little bit and it now has
positional audio
keep in mind that this is just a sample
game it's not complete it's just made to
kind of
test aspects of the engine and see what
i can implement
logically so i've got a little
background music that plays
and of course the laser sound
and when you blow up an asteroid you get
a sound now this one is positioned
based on your ship here right being you
know to its right and left behind
it's left so if something blows up on
your right you should hear it on your
right speaker right headphone
and likewise for the left it's hard to
tell in a lot of these cases since
you're generally shooting in front of
you
if you like shoot and turn
you can sometimes tell
well this seems to all work okay however
i did notice that if i put this in debug
it crashes so i need to address that
there's always something
there's always something well that's
pretty much it for this
uh vlog about the improvements and the
changes on ancient archer is still
continuing it is still in development
i kind of poke at it here and there
you're welcome to support this channel
here on patreon or if you go to my
ancient archer project you'll see some
links there to directly support
that project it's actually more of a
personal one not directly related to the
channel but it just happens to be
something cool to show
on this channel at the same time hope
you all have enjoyed
let me know if you have any questions
comments or anything like that below
and i'll see you guys in the next one
and a special shout out and thanks to
nasser al audi i hope i said your name
right
who has joined over on patreon and has
voted for some topics
to uh sponsor for me to work on so the
next few videos you see from this
channel
will be brought to you by his feedback
over there and his willingness to help
out so head on over there and sign up if
you would like to be part of that
we also do have a discord and i am live
on there and always answering questions
for whatever you might have or any
suggestions or anything
is the best way to get in contact with
me reliably i do appreciate
all of you watching and any of you
willing to support i would greatly
appreciate it as well
thanks again and have a nice day